the Parliament voted against launching  negotiations on updating copyright rules  that date back 17 years as a result the  proposal will now be debated and voted  in the September plenary session  Parliament sent proposals on rest time  rules  the transport of goods by non-resident  hall ears and the posting of lorry  drivers back to the Transport Committee  the regulation would apply to any  vehicle over 2.4 tons members voted on  the first-ever European defense industry  fund which has a budget of 500 million  euros it should make the EU more  independent and boost defence innovation  Bulgaria handed over the presidency of  the European Council to Austria leaders  of the two countries debated legislative  progress with members members agreed to  strengthen cooperation and data sharing  between Europol and eight Middle Eastern  and North African countries Jordan  Turkey Israel Tunisia Morocco Lebanon  Egypt and Algeria  [Music]